okay so this was um this is the series
right that we were contemplating now
what I want to do as you've seen before
in this topic I want to think about a
way to visualize what this looks like
and to do it in successive steps so
here's the way I've chosen to go about
it do you agree that this is a way of
just visualizing
a quarter are you okay with that taking
a square have it have it the whole
square if that's a quarter what's the
whole square a whole unit right so it'd
be 1 times 1 ok let's try and understand
what's going on here now this is only
the first term in the series what would
the next term look like how do we
visualize it's 1/16 isn't it I covered
it up sorry about that how do I
visualize 1/16 what do you think 1/4 of
1/4 so I've got many fourths quarters to
choose from here but in order to get a
pattern sort of set up here what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna say this quarter
I'm gonna take it up into this corner
over here okay are you with me so far
so this is just the first two terms in
our partial sum okay
now once I realize I've got this pattern
set up if I want to continue the next
one is 1 over 64 well if this is a
quarter of a quarter then 1 over 64 is a
quarter of a quarter of a quarter right
so in other words I can just sort of
keep on going there's 1 over 64
now hopefully you can see the limiting
sum is kind of forming before your eyes
I just need to continue the pattern
right and just sort of go further and
further and further and it at a certain
point I got too lazy and couldn't
animate them anymore so what are we
looking at here and how can we make
sense of the number the answer you came
up with well do you notice by the way
the shape is called a fractal it's sort
of the same shape sort of copied over
and over again sort of going off into
infinity
do you agree now in particular I want
you to notice each yellow square each
yellow square it sort of has two
corresponding squares that are the same
size does that make sense like every
yellow square has two other squares that
are the same size every single way all
the way along right so the question is
like the sum of this JP
limiting some is what's yellow that's
the question right but for every yellow
part there's two other parts that aren't
yellow does that make sense so that's a
third of this part that's a third of
this part and a third and a third and a
third are you getting a sense of why we
should actually have expected 1/3 all
the way from the beginning so it makes
sense so if you want I'm gonna disappear
it in a second but you may like to draw
this right that's just a visual
representation of the limiting sum that
you just calculated okay all right now
while you are doing that I'll give you a
second we can get the lights again now I
want to see if you can take this and
apply it to a thing that you learn like
four or five years ago and I'm just
going to sneak it over here so that I
don't have to put the screen up just yet
as you can see on this outline I want us
to see if we can take this idea of a
limiting Psalm and apply it to this why
don't we call these guys when you've got
a decimal that repeats over and over
again a recurring decimal in fact
spoilers I've wrote it on the board
right above there this is a recurring
decimal we can express this recurring
decimal as a limiting sum
have you any of you in the homework had
a look at a question like this hmm all
right in that case I'm going to pause
and I want you to jot down this
particular recurring decimal it 0.37 37
37 etc if you're lazy you can write a
zero point three seven with the dots
above the three and the seven and I'm
just going to give you a little bit of
time first before we unpack it for you
how might you express this for starters
as a geometric progression at all it
looks like just a number right how might
we express this is a series and then
secondly how can we identify the
limiting sum that's inside it so have a
think see if I can get okay
let's unpack this now I said this just
arrived before and I'll repeat it to
everyone I apologize that this starts
off shouting vague it's hard to explain
this in like a with with a clue without
just giving away the question entirely
so that is what I'm about to do I'm
gonna give away the question entirely
okay now here's what I want you to
remember and I've left this series over
here so that we can kind of make it a
bit more obvious right
what you've got is a bunch of terms that
each get successively smaller and I've
sort of highlighted here with different
colors you've got terms here that even
though they're written is one number I
can write them separately and sure that
they get smaller and smaller and smaller
so let's just look at the first part
okay if we just said 0.37 as a fraction
how would you write that it's 37 over a
hundred right 37 over a hundred now if i
were then to say take the next part of
the number it's tricky because decimals
sort of mush everything together but
what you've really got here in the next
instance is zero zero three seven do you
see that photo right that red part just
on its own how would I write that as a
fraction and you're still thinking in
decimals right how do I do this
thirty-seven over how much how many
zeros it's gonna be it's gonna be four
zeros which is ten thousand right now I
could write thirty-seven over ten
thousand but instead I'm gonna write it
as one hundred squared okay now why is
that helpful to me well even though ten
sorry ten thousand is a hundred squared
I'm trying to pull out the fact that
there's a common ratio from one term to
the next all right one last one let's
have a look just here the third one that
I've got and we always go to three when
we're trying to establish a pattern
right is um four zeros and then comes
the three seven right so how do I write
this guy as a fraction
37 over a hundred cubed and you can
check it has the right number of zeros
you can pop down to your calculator to
confirm if you like so now I've said it
all up I've got an A I'm going to need a
fraction and a fraction here I'm gonna
need to identify what my R is but
hopefully I've written the successive
fractions in a way that makes it
reasonably clear how do I multiply to
get from one turn to the next hmm
so I squared is is this squared from
this is this square roots going in any
direction
hmm what does a hundred squared mean
anyway it means 100 times 100 yeah
that's right two decimal points for so I
have to multiply by to make it a hundred
times smaller right and then I have to
multiply to make it a hundred times
smaller again that's why it's a hundred
cubed are you with me
so therefore the ratio should be one
over a hundred because that's how much
smaller I make it every single time
okay now we're sort of at this point
that way we just need to carry out the
arithmetic and do a question or thought
so if I was trying to work out what the
nth term is I would say it'll be a times
R to the power of n minus one exactly
like you said but in this case I'm
actually not trying to work out the end
of term I'm trying to work out the sum
of all the terms hence limiting some
yeah so let's go ahead and tidy this up
there's our numerator what do I get on
the denominator one takeaway one over
100 come on guys I know it's I know it's
warming your brains overheating but you
guys can manage this guy for me
this is 99 over 100 thank you by the way
why am i writing so many unnecessary
brackets yeah cuz I know I'm going to
miss read my own fractions right and
fractures odd fractures you're asking to
be making mistakes
what can I cancel the 100 here and the
100 here and this is a result you may
recall
all the way back from u7 you're like ah
I can get given a recurring decimal
you're like ah okay this is this is what
we all knew about but it took us four
and a half years to get you to the point
where you understood the theory as to
why we needed limits and other fancy
stuff okay this is making sense you with
me all right so there's our application
as recurring decimal